we're beginning with two panels two
projects today that are focused on
preserving legal and judicial content on
the web both of these projects are
relatively new but have already gotten a
considerable amount of attention both
within the law library community and
actually in mainstream media more as
well so you may well be aware of them
and I think that speaks to thee to the
benefits that people are seeing for for
society in their work I'll just
introduce the speakers very briefly and
that tells you what we're going to do
throughout the day I'm just going to say
who they are not what they've done and
let them tell you about what they're
working on so we're first starting with
Brian Carver and like a listener from
the pre-law project which is coming out
of Berkeley and now is a separate in
organization makes it more about that
and they'll be followed by Sheldon
Thomas and Jack Cushman from the Berkman
Center at Harvard talking about the perm
icici project Oh fine hi everybody I am
Brian Carver and that's my co-founder
michael listener there so let me you
know something about us now let me find
out something about my audience are
there any law librarians out there those
know anybody with a law degree of some
sort okay how about okay former I'll
take anybody who's been to a conference
before where the word metadata was used
more than once okay okay these are my
people I can talk to you guys so what
are we Michael was a former student of
mine at the UC Berkeley School of
Information and he started this project
as a masters final project and that was
over five years ago now it has taken on
a life of its own and we spun it off
into a non-profit a couple years ago our
primary objective is to provide free
online access to primary legal materials
by which we largely mean Court opinions
but we also want to develop legal
research tool
make those documents more accessible and
we find that we do a lot of support for
academic research on this corpora or on
these corpora because we get researchers
contacting us all the time saying WOW
nobody else makes this available we're
so excited to play with your data and
this primarily shows up at court
listener calm it's the primary
repository for all of our materials and
it has things like search and a site
ater and when you look at a given
opinion you can get a table of
authorities showing you all the
documents that its sights and these
sorts of things this is a sort of
out-of-date screenshot but we have over
I think now 2.6 million court opinions
there and our goal is to put the
entirety of us case law online for the
public for free now if you're outside of
the legal universe you might have
thought isn't this a solved problem
right and it's far from it certainly
westlaw and lexus have all of us case
law these are very expensive
subscriptions that I think no member of
the average public has access to there
are some free services that have a lot
of us case law google scholar is great
you know use that when you need to but
no one has all of it it available for
free for the public online so we're
trying to get there one of the ways that
we address that is with a project we
call jura scraper it's our system for
harvesting the court opinions that come
out each day i should say we think of
the problem of putting the entirety of
us case law online as breaking into
these two parts we have
daily problem that is they keep
producing new stuff every weekday and so
dura scraper really is addressed to that
but we also have a back catalogue
problem and that's actually harder to
solve is going back and getting all the
old opinions in digital format and
putting them online nobody's done it yet
and so we keep trying to find sources
for this material but the the daily
problems actually easier to solve in we
feel like we're pretty close after
completing the work under this grant
actually because we now cover all the
state courts of last resort we use that
ungainly phrase because not every state
calls its highest court a Supreme Court
but we now cover whatever their highest
court is in each state and most of the
intermediate appellate courts it turns
out that a few have really frustrating
websites that are still giving us fits
but lots of special jurisdictions are
covered your tax courts and court of
international trade but basically we
watch a couple hundred websites every
day right for changes and for new
documents another thing we're doing is
partnering with Princeton Center for
information technology policy on
something we call recap it's been around
for about five years as well it you
might notice from the logo that recap is
pacer spelled backwards that's supposed
to be really clever and the pacer system
is the electronic documents filing
system and public access system for your
federal district courts and now
increasingly the federal courts of
Appeal there's a pay wall at pacer of
ten cents a page ten cents a page even
for searches not just documents and so
this makes archiving that material on
your own enormously expensive Justice
Roberts recently put out a report where
he said there's over a billion
retrievable documents in the pacer
system
we sort of threw out a ballpark figure
of if they averaged just six pages per
document which we think is low it would
only cost you six hundred million
dollars right to buy all of the pacer
documents so that's off the table so if
we can't buy them what can we do
crowdsource it essentially right recap
is a suite of extensions that you can
plug into your Chrome or Firefox browser
and then as you buy documents from the
pacer system it automatically uploads
those to the Internet Archive Thank You
Brewster and so we're creating a free
public archive of these documents a
little bit at a time we sort of feel
like by collecting the ones that people
are willing to pay for maybe we're even
getting the most important ones I and
Michael's going to have more to say
about recap tomorrow well is it today
okay the lightning talks are today you
get to hear about that later so I
mentioned there's also all of these
additional sort of research tools on the
court listener site because we we don't
want to just give the public access to
these documents I think too frequently I
encounter public access systems that
have this terrible search interface or
you know utterly unusable tools built on
top of them and I think that's unfair
I'm maybe not trying to compete with
lexus or westlaw but I certainly can do
better than some of the things I've seen
government agencies put out we we also
have an API that allows other sites to
interact with all of our documents and
and reuse those on their own sites in a
lot of interesting ways I could say more
about but what we got to get to is what
did you do with our money correct what
was this grant about well here's one of
the things we this giant list of
jurisdictions that we now cover are just
the states and that was the the first
part of this we started with way fewer
than that
injury scraper we want to get metadata
that is as close to perfect as we can
get it and so we found that sort of
trying to build one scraper to rule them
all is just not going to work out every
court has their own little unique
website and their own way of presenting
the documents and it's extremely
frustrating sometimes to deal with their
bad HTML and other things that we
encounter we love it if we get a nice
table that shows us the case name and
the URL to the PDF that they're going to
provide usually is right there and there
may be the date that the opinion was
issued is in another column that's nice
but you also find insane things like
people who only create a PDF list of new
opinions and once you click through to
that PDF then you will find internal
links to the actual documents and that
link exists nowhere else on the web
except inside this PDF you know and so
we have to find ways to deal with these
kinds of things and so each of these
unique websites requires us to have sort
of a little recipe for dealing with each
website that's turned out to be a
benefit to the project as a whole
because we want to attract lots of other
contributors and and and people to help
us in this task it is an open source
project as well and so what those little
individual recipes do for us is create a
really nice entry point for new
developers if somebody does get
interested in what we're up to and they
say how can we help we say well if you
know even a tiny bit of Python you could
probably build a scraper for us right
that these individual website recipes as
I've been calling them are sometimes
just 56 lines long here's an example and
like the first 13 lines of that is
commentary right where we're just
keeping track cooking so the and they
follow a little
ANZ's that are very easy to figure out
once you once you get into it and so
people look at that if we direct them to
this first and they're like oh okay I
could do that right and and then if you
do that there's this really amazing
thing that happens you know a day later
we make it live on the website and now
all the sudden the Court of Appeal for
Arizona is producing documents on our
website you know and you get to see the
impact of your work very rapidly so this
modular approach to things allows us to
get that specificity that we want with
regards to the metadata for for each
particular court that we deal with while
we also as much as possible try to
generalize out into the the core of jura
scraper the things that are the same
across all the sites so to get try and
give you one example there are some
things that we want to always be the
same within our metadata for instance
early on on the site I noticed that we
were getting case names that would say
United States versus holder us versus
holder USA vs holder capital u lowercase
s lower ka versus holder and every
variation there on right and I was like
this is this is ugly this is terrible
there is a standardized way to refer to
case names that the blue book has
provided us we need to just you know
standardize all of these and make it
always say you know United States or
something right capital u lowercase n I
teach you know and so that's something
that now is handled at a higher level
and our individual contributors never
need to think about those kinds of
things right they can just deal with
grabbing the documents so results on
that front when we started this grant we
had 87 scrapers dealing with state
courts and when we finished we had 154
and since completing that work we've
added over 58,000 state court opinions
to our archive but I want to say maybe
quickly here is the best place to insert
one other thing that we do
we do care about the born digital nature
of these documents and sometimes i
frustrate Mike with this proclivity but
I want to save them all if a court puts
out a unique document then even when
they come back later and make a
correction or change I I want to keep
them all right and so recently there was
even in the news an instance where
Justice Scalia modified his opinion you
may have read this in the new york times
and it was one of those rare instances
where the change actually seems somewhat
substantive you know and so we're going
to catch that sort of thing if you put
it on your website we're checking it all
the time and so we're going to get
version one we're going to get version
two where you get version 3 and we've
actually found that researchers are
sometimes interested in this professor
peter martin at cornell now emeritus is
fascinated by this issue and is written
about it and uses our data to see what
the courts are up to when they make
these silent revisions but what else did
we do with your money so we call the
site court listener in part as a pun
based on Michaels last name lists and RL
is s in ER but also because for a very
long time I've been concerned about oral
argument audio files most appellate
courts hold oral argument and the
litigants get to come and present their
case to a panel of judges and many
courts for a long time have been
recording these sessions and I remember
even 12 15 years ago being distraught
over the fact that at that time storage
was not as cheap as it is today and the
Ninth Circuit was putting these mp3
files and wav files and other things on
their website but cycling them off after
about three months they would just sort
of disappear and no one knew where they
went right or if they were being saved
or what and I just start the archivist
in me starts going are those being
deleted what
happening to those right because this is
a very valuable resource for scholars
and so I've wanted us to be collecting
these oral argument audio files for a
long time now we do it's subtle in this
image but the underlined in red on the
left hand side shows you that now we
have oral arguments not just opinions
and to date we have over 10,000 of these
when you click on a particular one
here's a recent one from the Supreme
Court a little player appears now and
you can also download these as a podcast
if you're a real you know fed court
junkie and and have these set to your
phone on a regular basis but um but yeah
you can even mix you can make your own
customized podcast that's right um
getting just those cases that involve
the EEOC for instance if that's your
thing right we save the original audio
file whatever the court puts up but then
also we found that they're terrible and
they have awful metadata and so we
create our own modified version of the
file that has like an album cover
that'll show you a pretty picture of the
Ninth Circuit or you know and it says
what this thing is what this file is
other than some random string of numbers
and make that available to folks if they
if they want that as well and when we
started this grant we had zero oral
argument audio files and today it's over
two hundred and fifty seven days of
listening time we there's a website you
can go to that shows you how long it
would take to say watch all of the
simpsons or all of the sopranos or you
know pick your favorite show and
actually you can pick about a dozen of
those and you could watch all of those
four times and still not be the same
amount of content
that we have already in terms of oral
argument audio right now one thing that
was significant about this though for us
in terms of our internal infrastructure
was it added an entirely new type of
thing that we were collecting we went
from just documents just court opinions
to now also collecting these media files
and that implied some back-end changes
to our database and an other internal
infrastructure that's going to be really
important for us going forward because
when we and i say win not if when we
merge all those documents that we're
collecting from recap into the court
listener database recap collects every
kind of document that appears on a court
docket not just the judges opinions but
the complaint the briefs any
declarations etc and so each of these
different document types will probably
get treated differently in our system
and now we have sort of a template for
how to do that when we've set up the
infrastructure to say okay this is an
opinion this is a audio file this is
something else and so we're really well
positioned to take that next step the
the group DC legal hackers was very
impressed by this work and named our
oral argument audio collection a legal
hack of the year for 2014 so Columbia
deserves some credit for that too you
should pat yourself on the back ok so in
summarized that a little we completed
our daily coverage right of all 50
states even some states with really
terrible websites added these oral
argument audio scrapers added this open
source audio player to the site and made
the system now capable of recognizing
these multiple types of documents this
was not without some pain PDFs are just
the worst and they're great for
individual readers write it works on
your Mac it works on Windows we can
understand why pdfs exists
right but maybe not some of you are like
no no I don't understand it but I guess
in my view the courts are publishers
right and they ought to be thinking of
themselves as publishers and they ought
to want to pursue best practices within
the publishing industry and
unfortunately they seem to feel that you
know sort of technology in the
publishing industry Pete with the
invention of PDF and nothing has
happened since right you know that that
we now have reached our final in state
of perfection and that's just not so it
creates all sorts of problems for us
having to parse these things while
they're great for humans they're not
great for computers is basically the
problem extracting the metadata that we
would really want out of these things is
insane and so I would love it if I could
persuade more courts to create some sort
of more machine friendly format even if
it's in the background and i just
downloaded in bulk and the general
public never knows about it I've spoken
before at the National Conference for
appellate court clerks there is such a
conference it's actually a lot of fun
those people know how to party at but
the the court clerks are sort of open to
this some of them you know and they view
the their job is making these things
available to the public and they're like
Brian if there's a way that we can make
it easier for third-party publishers
like you you know let us know and so I
hope in the future I can work with some
of them to get these more machine
friendly formats out there now that
we're collecting all this audio we
really wish we had transcripts right the
court doesn't provide them and so we've
looked at a lot of tools that would
automate transcription and none of them
are free that we know of if you have
ideas on how to do 257 days worth of
audio at low-cost or no-cost that's what
we would prefer then that's that would
be of great interest to discuss and and
when you're monitoring a couple hundred
websites sort of maintenance is a pain
if a website makes one change to how
they display their documents it might
break my scrapers and so we've set up a
intense monitoring system we Mike and I
get an email every afternoon letting us
know sort of you know which scrapers
made noise today like something might be
wrong and then we can go investigate and
we've tried to be smart even about that
by learning things like judges like to
take a break just like faculty members
and sometimes there's a three-month
period where no opinions are coming out
and that's not because anything's broken
but it's because they're you know out of
session and so we've tried to do things
like have that status report email show
us what's an average number of documents
out of this court per week or per 10
days or per month and how many have we
gotten recently and it's only when you
start to see something that looks
outside the norm that you really have to
worry but then another thing we've found
in doing this work is that especially at
the state court level they're
increasingly jumping right past
providing oral argument audio and going
straight to video and so we would love
to start collecting that it's a lot it's
even more fun to watch the judges and
the litigants make their cases than it
is to listen to it and that's that's
probably something we'll get into it and
deal with new and interesting problems
there but thinking beyond the law the
the jura scraper infrastructure actually
teaches us a lot I think about archiving
in general if you need to monitor a lot
of websites and collect documents from
them I think there would be something to
be gained from studying the way jura
scraper approaches it in particular the
modularity right of figuring out what do
all my sites have in common and making
that the core and then customizing for
each individual page something much
smaller that hand
that unique specificity allows you to
distract that balance of getting
precisely the metadata you want right
you know if you try to use some generic
library to just parse every page the
same way I think you're going to end up
with a lot of problems and your metadata
things that you're going to have to go
back and correct later and we can solve
for that in the first instance when
we're collecting it so you know you
could change all of our database names
from referring to courts to referring to
something else and go to town one
example that I've long wanted to have
time to build I'm sort of overly
involved in my local municipalities
politics and so cities post the minutes
of the Planning Commission and the
agendas for the city council meeting and
all sorts of documents on their website
and sometimes video and audio and they
have terrible search interfaces on the
city websites and so I go there trying
to search for something and I can't find
that agenda from 2014 about you know so
i would i would love to ingest you know
all of the city's documents and make
them searchable in the same way that
court listeners has made court documents
work and the shift from collecting court
opinion documents to collecting city
documents would be very seamless right
you could use the same infrastructure
quite easily one nice thing about both
of those examples though is that we
avoid copyright problems right
everything I work with is in the public
domain and if anyone you know says
otherwise I'll fight them about it right
and so I feel fine you know collecting
all this and redistributing it to the
public as soon as you decide oh I want
to turn this on to you know academic
journal articles or some other domain
maybe you might have to talk to your
copyright lawyer but we also think we
learned a lot in doing the harvesting of
audio
the stuff that Mike did to improve the
metadata on our version of the file is
are the kinds of lessons that would be
useful to anybody trying to archive
audio and in the same way the jura
scraper framework could could be used to
collect you know audio of people telling
stories about World War 2 or you know
whatever collection is out there that's
an audio format and you decide you want
to collect it you could turn the same
frame work towards it fairly simply I
think so we we're all over the place
free Law Project Aware court listener
calm recap the law out of work and all
over Twitter get in touch we'd love to
hear more from you and learn from you as
well I'm supposed to save time for
questions what have you got yeah wait
for the mic i think they want to record
you hi thanks very interesting
presentation three questions one is you
mentioned that some of the court clerks
are sort of sympathetic to your work or
the idea of improving their own output
accessibility are you getting a lot of I
it makes me think that at some stage or
at least with some jurisdictions it
might be more efficient instead of
working on programming and reprogramming
scrapers to simply get them to deposit
their stuff with you yeah that
possibility yeah so that sounds like one
of three questions let me take them one
at a time though so I remember one thing
that we've thought about is when we
encounter these terrible websites we've
thought why don't we just make a
template you know website of here's your
opinion listings right and if we design
it and if even two courts adopted it my
life is that much easier right because
now the exact same template is being
used in two places all right and it's
not yet another unique thing for me to
deal with and so we've thought about
that
usually though you know kourt's contract
with somebody to create an entire
website overhaul and then whatever
system that is create some kind of page
that they decide to list their documents
on and we have to end up dealing with
that but well in there has been one
effort by a colleague to try and create
this sort of depository approach by
basically creating for the Dropbox for
the courts almost right you know where
you would say look i'm going to give you
this little sort of cloud storage space
and i want you to put your opinions in
there in preferably in their original
doc or whatever format we still find
kourt's using word perfect but they can
cling to old technology like no one else
and it the idea is that it might be
easier to get that machine friendly
format if we did have access on a
regular basis to the original word
processing format because you could well
and it's also sort of a human problem
because I think really the the easiest
thing would be if you could get judges
to adopt a microsoft word template right
for their opinions and you marked up
that template with various styles then
the translation of that to something
like XML could be automated really
easily right but judges are used to
doing their own thing and answering to
no one right so so telling them you must
use this template for your writing your
opinion is going to be a hit or miss
sort of enterprise but with a couple
jurisdictions we feel like we could
maybe come close right says he's got
three sorry alcohol brush through them
the second one was just sorry for my
naivete on this point but with regard to
the oral argument audio and video
doesn't the court produce its own
official transcript of these
no don't have a court yeah gadget
they're typing away in no it turns out
that's very expensive and so it and it's
becoming a problem even at trials and in
other places where you really think that
there ought to be a transcription
there's a situation now in california
and alameda county where we are we're in
some instances they require the litigant
to pay for their own court reporter and
if your indigent right then this looks
like a really bad situation and
especially if you want to appeal you've
got to have a record of what happened
below and so anyway no it's not not
currently created um thank you pipe up
to Brian there's a good article in
Boston calm I think the headline was you
can buy a land rover or you can buy the
transcript to the boston marathon
bombing that's the scale we're talking
about just for these for these
transcripts yeah last one last one real
quick are you aware of any parallel kind
of projects for the rest of the world
outside the US yes we're part of what's
called the free access to law movement f
alm that you can look up online that's
another URL i could have given you and
there are these legal information
institutes for over a hundred different
countries i think and so there's
somebody working on this all over the
world yeah i just want to point out that
these are all exactly the same problems
that we've been dealing with for the
last 16 years in collecting academic
journals extracting metadata cleaning it
up all those kinds of things scraping
sites that change all the time they're
all exactly the same problems and i just
want to issue a warning don't get too
enthusiastic about formats formats
evolved through time in ways that make
them much more difficult to deal with
for reasons that we take too long to go
into but basically we're set out by ivan
sutherland bob sproul in the 60s
so for example we see that HTML used to
be easy to deal with now it's html5 and
it's actually mostly JavaScript so it's
actually a program not a document any
longer this will happen to every single
format that you think you want to
standardize on so you can't get out of
this problem by saying oh we've got a
mandate that everybody uses this format
because what will happen is that that
format will adapt to deal with the same
forces that are causing the
proliferation of formats so suck it up
this is something we have to deal with I
think I would largely agree but just
just quickly add the so what's worse
about PDF is that it's a proprietary
binary format right and if i could get
people to switch to xml or json sure 10
years from now there will be xml pro or
JSON plus i don't care what they change
it to it's still a text-based format
that i ought to be able to translate one
to the new you know fancy thing that's
come along much more easily than we can
right now dealing with the the binary
proprietary formats we're stuck with
we're here from permit CC which is a
platform that we created at harvard law
school library our keynote set us up
really nicely because we are alarmist
scenario number one which is the
researcher who is disagrees with a
particular paper that they've read but
all of the links in the citations of
broken and there's no way that they can
sort of follow the the rabbit hole
that's its broken links all the way down
so the idea for Parma actually came out
of a paper that sort of confirmed our
suspicions that alarmist scenario number
one was indeed happening a number of
colleagues a two years ago or so at the
Harvard Law School Library went through
and found that in a representative
sample of links in the Harvard Law
Review 73
sent of the links were broken that and
those were in just the last 10 years
then they did a follow-up study with the
Supreme Court opinions and found it over
fifty percent of links ever cited by the
Supreme Court were broken now this is a
huge problem in terms of academic
integrity when you think about it in law
reviews but when it comes to the courts
it's even bigger problem because it
becomes sort of beloved that governs our
very society one particular 404 of note
is here I don't know if you guys can
read it but it says aren't you glad you
didn't cite to this webpage in the
supreme court reporter at Brown v
entertainment it gives the case citation
if you had like Justice Alito did the
original content would have long since
disappeared and someone else might have
come along and purchased the domain in
order to make a comment about the
transience of linked information in the
Internet age we that has become sort of
our poster child for perma so we thought
wow this is a really big problem someone
should do something about this so then
we SAT around and twiddle our thumbs a
little bit and then said well why don't
we try to do something about it and so
along with the team but Jack works with
the Harvard library law library
innovation lab we created permit CC
which is a platform that allows authors
and editors to archive web pages that
their sighting in their articles with us
but also with a distributed network of
libraries that mirror our sort of
central archive it's very simple to use
you essentially just go there's a very
inviting URL box you just throw in
whatever URL you're citing to it spits
back success we've archived it and then
when readers follow that permalink that
you can put into a citation they're met
with this which allows them to see both
I don't know if you can read the
abs are sort of small but the furthest
one on the left is the live page view it
allows them to see what is at that site
right now this is nice because not only
does it give the rear a sense of what's
at the URL currently it also turns the
turn styles at the whoever owns the
actual website so we're not diverting
any content from those websites they
still get all their ad revenue and all
those other things then we do a screen
capture and a work archive capture so
depending on what you want the archive
for we have a few different types of
archive we've had a unprecedented at
least in our sort of wildest dreams
amount of success this two years ago
this was sort of an idea and thanks to
some generous articles in the New York
Times and and The New Yorker we have had
a lot of success in getting this out
into law journals this is these are
permalinks being used in a harvard law
review article right now we have about i
think between 170 and 200 law journals
right now putting permalinks in their
citations around the country and the
beauty of the way permit is set up is
that we i don't know if anyone knows how
the DNS system works for for websites
but it's sort of like that we give sort
of blessing power to libraries at
institutions all across the country and
they give they sort of bless their
journals with accounts that allow their
journals to create permanent archive so
while there are almost 200 law journals
across the country using perma we've
interacted with a tiny fraction of that
and it's sort of become a
self-sustaining system which has been
really great for scale we've also had
some success with courts so this is a
Fifth Circuit opinion in which
permalinks are being used we the the
courts that we have right now are a
little bit scattershot we have the
courts
Michigan the appellate court in the
Supreme Court we have the Supreme
Judicial Court of Massachusetts the
Supreme Court for the US Virgin Islands
I volunteer to do on-site training for
them but that didn't pan out and a few
other judges at courts where the whole
court hasn't signed on but particular
judges are starting to put our links
into their opinions which is great
because then hopefully those will never
break what are sort of most recent
success is one of our most notable ones
that step we have recently been included
in the Blue Book I don't know how many
law scholars or librarians that are in
the room from the poll earlier maybe not
many but the blue book is a wonderful
document it's about 500 pages of
citation rules and standards that that
are used throughout all of both legal
scholarship and practice they in the new
edition that just came out or is just
coming out this summer they've added a
bit on web archiving and perma was
fortunate to be the example archive that
they use when they tell lawyers and law
students and judges how to cite to
archives so hopefully if people sort of
build that into their workflows all of
their cited web content will forever be
archived and just to give you a sense of
the numbers over the last about 20
months we've had about a hundred
thousand links archived and we have
almost a hundred library partners that
have signed on to help their journals at
their respective schools start using the
system and eventually we hope to expand
those partnerships to actually mirroring
the content we have a few partners that
mirror us right now but we're hoping
that a number of our other hundred
partners will start mirroring the
content so that if it goes down it one
University you can access it through any
number of
other universities and now I'm going to
turn it over Jack who's going to tell
you a little bit more about how the
system actually works and what we did
with the grant thank you make sure so
yeah I'm Jack Cushman I'm a computer
programmer and a lawyer I work on a lot
of the guts of perma and I want to talk
about some of those guts and what we've
been working on in particular with
support from the Columbia incentive
award and from melon the new API that
we've recently launched in which I'm
very excited about so I'm going to tell
you about the number one primary
consumer of the perma API and five other
interesting uses of the API that we have
up and running before I do that I want
to do a little more sort of audience
participation stuff who gets like really
excited when you hear about a new API
that's available come on yes a bunch of
you this is such a great crowd I love
this I get really excited about a new
API because when you launch an API it's
like you're taking the brain of your
website and and opening it up to the
world before is protected by a user
interface now anyone in the world can
come along and just poke right and right
at your brain and that's really cool it
allows new things to happen with the
tools that you've built that you never
imagined on the other hand downsides of
AP is for those of you who didn't raise
your hands are not excited by DP is just
sort of you know in three seconds if you
can state in one sentence why you don't
like API is one two three go okay so
what I think I heard you say is we've
been burned by api's before that so what
goes wrong with API is there they're not
powerful enough they don't let you poke
at the part of the brain that you wanted
they change over time so like people
building the site oh really care about
them and so they stop working the way
you expected they're frustrating to use
because the people who built them don't
have to use them as themselves and so
they don't do what you wish they would
do a lot of problems that stop them from
realizing this awesome potential which
we didn't want and so what we've done is
to make sure that pro masisi itself is
API driven and you can follow along at
home with our
Pradaxa everything that you can do on
the primacy see website you're doing
through our API the website itself is
simply another consumer of the API so
for example shaylen showed you this sort
of form for creating new links when you
submit that form what's actually
happening through javascript is that
you're posting a request to our API to
create a new link so if you don't want
to use the form if you want to write a
program to do it you can just send that
post request and the same thing happens
on this other screen if you were to you
know dark archive a link that you had
created you'd be patching you know
sending another API request if you were
to go to manage your links and move
things around folders and share them
with organizations and change the
metadata on them and create new folders
all of the other stuff you can do you're
doing through our API and you could do
it your own way with your own software
through your own websites and this means
that our API is going to be powerful
enough because it does what we needed to
do it's going to be simple enough
because we would hate it if it wasn't
simple and it's going to keep working
because if it stops working then our
users will tell us right away that it
stopped working because they can no
longer put stuff in folders so we're
really excited about this API and I want
to bring along the rest of you who
didn't raise your hands I want you to be
excited about it too so I'm going to
tell you about some of the cool things
that we're doing with it and that other
people are doing with it why our API is
cool example number one is a software
called amber which is a project at the
Berkman Center it's like a server-side
archive so you can install like a
wordpress widget and every time you
create a blog post and link to something
a copy of the web pages that you link to
our store right there on your server
next to your blog post so that the links
break your readers can get to them it's
really cool stuff you should check that
out what we were able to do with the API
is in just you know a day or two kind of
throw in and I'll turn it back in for
Amber so that if you don't want to store
the stuff on your server next to your
blog post every time you create a URL
instead it gets sent to the perma API it
gets stored on our system you know
really straightforward simple thing to
build to kind of start expanding the way
that people can do this are cutting
example to a word integration another
sort of little project that we were able
to put together this is the worst
screenshot in the world because it
corrupted the part like that's
get line from the bottom where it's
supposed to say create permalink if you
can imagine it says create permalink
there so what you can do with this
plugin is you're an author you're
drafting along you include a web page
you want to make sure that your readers
can see the web page at the moment that
you're looking at it and it'll say what
you saw it to say so you can just sort
of right click on that link right inward
say create permalink and it pops in the
permalink right there you don't even
have to go to our website that's really
cool right everyone should have their
hands up number three the perma export
script that we put together a question
we get sometimes from courts especially
is suppose in the future we no longer
want to work with you we want to run our
own archive as host our own archives how
would we do that you know can we get our
data out so we put together this example
it's a simple Python script that grabs
all of your data from perma and exports
it in a form where if you download our
source code to run your own promo
website you can just stick this right in
and all of your links have come right
over this didn't require any kind of
special work on our part as sort of
being able to access the internals of
the system the data is there in the API
which means anyone can write the script
export it if you want it to run in
another system you could write your own
script to put it in whatever format you
wanted so we're giving this kind of
freedom to our users example for with
support from the grant we are able to
add memento compliance so we now have an
endpoint that lets all of the promo
archives that have been published and
are allowed to be public be discovered
through memento tools so that they can
pop up in browsers 1 links break and all
kinds of cool stuff that is possible to
do with Mentos that I hope other people
will tell you about later in the day
because it's super awesome but I don't
have time to dig into it an example of 5
which is the first example that wasn't
us building it is canary watch and
canary watch is a project by the eff and
some other folks to try to monitor those
warrant canary is that the library's
kicked off and then a bunch of sort of
other websites got on the board with
where the idea was if you've been
ordered to turn over user data and
you've been ordered not to tell people
about it that's a really concerning
thing for libraries and service
is so what you do is put on your website
we have never been ordered to turn over
data and then if you're a degenerate
over you take it back down and then
people notice that's not there anymore
and they can figure out what happened as
a lawyer I don't know if that really
works but a lot of people are excited
about it kaneria watch is a project
actually watched those statements and
see if they are taken down so that you
really they'll work what they've done
using the perma API is to when they're
watching these things and they see a
change in a warrant canary website to
grab a snapshot of the before and after
so that we'll have a real record of what
these weren't Canaries looked like it's
an example of the kind of thing that's
possible now that our brain is open to
the world and you can come poke at it
however you want so to close with that
what i would put to you is now we have
this thing out there a new tool and new
power tell us what else it's good for
start thinking about you know when you
have access to this kind of archival
service what can be done with it that's
what I got thank you so much
I think this obviously this is a great
service to have this this idea of
creating permalinks and then having them
and then being able to get to the
content that's on them it reminds me
though of like the National I'm of
Australia safe kept project which then
went away because the National I reverse
Julia decided that they just didn't want
to fund it anymore they couldn't keep
funding that so I'm curious about sort
of the governance and you mentioned you
have a lot of other partners and they're
mirroring the site but that's not quite
the same as having a long-term
preservation plan in place for governing
and making sure that these are actually
continually to be available through time
especially if now they're being cited
rather than other types of things yeah
what's your plan for that it's always
exciting to be on video for questions
like that broadly the plan is to launch
it and make it important and to build
the plane as we fly it in particular I
think that the reverse question would be
why do we still have the legal decisions
themselves from hundreds of years ago
and the answer is that libraries stepped
up to keep lots of copies of them where
we're working now to move the perma
mirroring system to locks as a back end
to a private locks network and so I
think the answer to that governance
question will be around how that private
locks network is constructed that piece
is not finished yet but I feel good
about the momentum that we have in our
plane and where we're headed I think
that's the best I can do right now
hi I had a question for both and I'm
interested in knowing what your
involvement and engagement with user and
research communities has been in terms
of just informing the development of
your resources but also in terms of
promoting them among researchers and not
just in LA but other fields that often
draw upon law and legal resources and
their research I have to say it's it's
kind of hard right you really do need to
be in touch with your users and try and
get the feedback wherever you can and i
think you know we have probably haven't
done the best we can for that we've done
pretty well i think on the api side we
get a lot of feedback on that and
because people you know these it guys
like we're saying they're pretty awesome
and people really care and there are
people who you know our developers are
kind of on the same so I think there can
be sort of an impedance mismatch
sometimes between like developers and
lawyers and your audience and getting
fast that can be kind of challenging i
would say that we've benefited a lot
from being part of a library system so
our connection to our users is not just
through you know the few of us who are
working on the project but through
dozens of libraries that are each sort
of reaching out to their journals and
the piece that we're working on now is
bridging the gap between the law
libraries and the sort of larger library
world and we have a few non law
libraries on board now remember what
those are soon um we the the bodily and
at Oxford princeton university libraries
a few others that I can't remember off
the top of my head but certainly law is
only phase one in our move towards world
domination but but I think if libraries
are so important and one of the
questions you've had is well now that
students aren't reading books anymore
certainly is a law student I didn't go
to the library for books what are they
doing I think this is we're an example
of where libraries are so important in
the relationship with users can I ask
student talk about your concept of
vesting do you guys really think that
that has to involve a human checking the
content and confirming something or can
you imagine a scenario where what
matters is the timeliness with which
this link was archived or something and
so even a computer could say yes I want
to vest that because it is what I want
it to be you know sure so as as context
for those of you aren't familiar with
the site we have the concept now of a
second step after you create a link
where a user who has been blessed by
library vests it which means it will be
kept permanently and kept in the
collection of the Harvard Law Library to
a large extent having vesting is an
aspect of getting that plane launched
with the authority of the Harvard
University that a sort of opening up
shop for the world and not just saying
we're serving our students but we're
serving you know everyone and give us
what you have and we'll keep it forever
on our shelf having a kind of gatekeeper
step is valuable to make it possible to
make that offer and to get it out into
the world and it gets it courts using it
I think that from a technical
perspective and over the long term we
would hope to find less friction e ways
to make that possible and I wouldn't be
surprised to see other ways happen but
we don't have a particular game plan for
what that would be and especially in the
context of academia vesting at least to
date has sort of served the purpose of
the check is more than just oh this is
the time this is in fact the time that I
wanted something archived it is sort of
a editor or author reader relationship
in the form of a citation saying like I
am a human I have checked this this is
in fact what I want you my reader to see
and so starting out in legal academia
that proved to be valuable both in in
sort of getting the plane off the ground
and selling it to journals and libraries
who are really sort of looking for where
their role in the
future of web web archiving is but i
agree with jack that we're looking
towards ways of making that system work
a little more smoothly maybe what's hard
is that the idea is if a person has to
look invest and say yes this is the
right thing I'm going to show it to my
readers in practice people tend to leap
that hurdle very quickly and we've run
some statistics that people are you know
you create it and then 45 seconds later
it's invested every time and and you
start to feel like okay this hurdle
isn't necessarily doing what we wanted
to do is there another way to have that
happen David so yeah this is actually a
very important part of the process
because one thing that isn't a really
obvious to most people is that every
time anybody looks at a website it's
potentially very different and in
particular a lot of we see this all the
time so for example the Internet Archive
claims to have mementos of a lot of
academic journals what they have is a
page saying you do not have access to
this journal because you don't have a
subscription and telling the difference
between that page which is served with a
200 result code and the actual page
which is also served with a 200 request
code is not that easy for programs so we
have to do this on a sample basis for
journals and it's clearly in terms of
saying this is what I cited get making
sure that what you saw when you saw the
page and what perma CCC's when it sees
the page from a different IP address
later is is very very important and i
might say largely that becomes a matter
of user education as much as interface
yeah could both projects talk about the
issue of what i'll call stable documents
versus dynamic documents and also the
issue of migration technology migration
versus executable in other words looking
at it in the context of the way of how
it was created versus migrating the
technology forward in terms of the
applications that are available in the
few
sure so in terms of capturing dynamic
content we use a technology stack but I
think it's a little bit different from
the kind of straw poll I saw it I IPC a
lot of people are using Hera tricks for
capturing we're using a stack that is a
Python package called the warp rocks for
a recording traffic and so we spin up a
phantom j/s headless browser we're out
all of the traffic through work prox and
record the full session which will
include any kind of JavaScript
interactivity stuff that's happening and
then we use a package called PI WB the
Python way back by Ilya Kramer to replay
those works so we get a fair bit of
interactivity in that process and then I
think there's a question of the format
conversion how long can you expect those
things to keep working what we've been
around for two years and they're working
so far my impression is that the the
correct answer is to always have the
original and to maintain the sort of
translation process that you need to
present it in a you know presentation
format to whoever your users are I think
it would be premature for us to invest
in that technology when we don't know
what the problems are going to be down
the road we are keeping the static
snapshot of each page so that we have at
least that reference point for what it
looked like to phantom j/s the headless
browser at that moment in time which
often is better even in the replay that
you get right after yeah so it shouldn't
be the case that we're interested in
dynamic documents usually they are
supposed to be you know the static
announcements of the court on some issue
but as I mentioned and I thought we find
actually sometimes they do change and
what we do is use a hashing algorithm to
check the document and see have we seen
this one before and it's when it's
different that we know something has
changed about that PDF that has the same
file name right you know but apparently
something has has changed and so we're
we were going to look for that anyway
because it actually makes our scraper
more friendly to the website we don't
download the same thing over and over
and over again and have some sense of
what have we seen before on the
technology upgrades you raise a really
good point
it is something Mike and I've thought a
lot about because there have been so
many failed projects in this exact space
that we're in before people try to
collect the entirety of us case law and
then they run out of funding or interest
and all their efforts go away I've seen
several of these sites disappear over
the years that I've watched this and we
tried to set things up from the outset
to make sure that we are the last people
who ever have to work on this issue and
the way we do that is by being
completely open source and open access
all our code is available on github you
can run court listener on your own
server today right all of our documents
are downloadable in bulk or via the API
and so you can download everything we
have and then import it into that free
open source code and and I've actually
many times at conferences challenged the
audience to if Mike and I you know meet
our demise in an unfortunate way we
expect one of you to pick up the task
and continue it that we've made that
possible and so no matter how things
change in the future we hope right that
we know one starts over at least so
we're refinements to a pic I'm just want
to say one thing that is we don't have
law librarians in the room much but the
director of our law library can either
used to ask me probably starting about
10 years ago he'd asked me once a year
what are we going to do about you know
making sure that the citations in legal
journals still work and maybe a couple
years ago he stopped asking me so
possibly this has to do with with the
work we've been hearing here